[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan have you
noticed a lot of empty shelves at stores
recently um
yeah the first snowflake
hits the ground
well not here in la but
other places i saw a meme about it like
uh yeah the first snowflake hits the
ground and all of a sudden there's no
bread and milk
or eggs
yeah i think if a snowflake hit the
ground in los angeles it'd be pure panic
right yeah yeah well not only are there
supply chain issues but there seems to
be
a whole lot of panic buying going on
today on the public podcast ryan and i
are talking about the psychology behind
all this panic buying then this thursday
on the minimalist private podcast we're
going to discuss how minimalists can
prepare for emergencies for pandemics
for supply chain shortages and for
financial shock events without
hoarding
i think that's the key you can check
that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
all right our first question today is
from mira on facebook
what causes panic buying in the first
place i think we have to talk about what
panic buying is so i think quite often
right now especially in times like this
we see a bunch of empty shelves or when
covid first started oh my goodness
remember you and i did this episode with
tk coleman and we got really frustrated
there was a guy who was like stealing or
not stealing but like buying up all the
hand sanitizer paper towels like
reselling them at i don't know eighteen
hundred percent markup or something
absurd like yeah and making up the
number but yeah i think amazon got sued
over it actually for letting people do
that oh wow yeah and so
that's one type of panic buying but i
would like to extend panic buying
i think people panic by
whenever there is a sort of perceived
loss yeah whenever they feel as though
they might be missing out so it's fomo
the fear of missing out
and what do we do so anytime someone
creates a false shortage of something or
a real shortage
creates a faux urgency we see this you
and i used to be in the sales world and
quite often by our bosses and by the
corporation itself we were encouraged to
create a false sense of urgency to get
someone to act now to buy now and that's
a sort of low-grade panic buy i'll tell
you what if you go ahead and buy this
today i'll waive your activation fee
yeah if you go ahead and buy this today
i will waive the points on the loan or
whatever it might be it'll cost you 500
less if i can get you in this car
right now
and it creates that sense of scarcity
that oh no i'm going to lose something
if i don't act now and so what does that
do
panicking is never rational right no one
panics rationally right in fact you
can't panic rashly panic is always an
irrational response to some sort of
stimuli in this case it's a shortage or
a perceived shortage yeah so we feel as
though oh no if i don't buy this now
then i may never have access to it when
i
need it yeah oh that's interesting man i
remember
uh the trader joe's near our place uh
when the pandemic happened yeah like the
shelves
just like
probably all the grocery stores across
the country were empty yes in fact i
remember a week later everything came
back in shelves were stocked trader
joe's had to put a
only two items uh only two of the same
item kind of restriction end to keep the
shelves from going bare again
which i don't understand like why all
stores just don't do that because
if you limit someone like hey we know
you want to buy everything but you're
going to be okay with just getting two
of this right and we'll have back in
stock next week right but if we panic
like that's when it starts to break down
but anyway
um i was talking to one of the cashiers
and they were saying that
they had um like the the best
week they've ever had by like 10 like it
was 10x
whatever they yeah whatever a normal
week was oh
because people were panicking yes and
that's my point is
corporations often
try to induce a low-grade panning now
they don't want to go over the top they
don't want you to truly panic and and
then you know you see the like the
doorbuster sales in our first film
minimalism
that is a type of of high-grade panic of
people actually trampling other human
beings literally the day after being
thankful for everything they have
and now it's the next day and now we're
going to trample other people because we
i think we just forgot about being
thankful now let's talk about the
essence of this where does it come from
it's about the fear of missing out well
there's only one way to combat the fear
of missing out
and that is to understand what enough
truly is yeah now you and i ryan we have
this uh we call it the no junk rule
and it's in our minimalist rule book 16
rules for living with less you can
download it for free on our website it's
theminimalists.com
rulebook yeah it's also in our book yeah
those rules yeah we put all 16 of them
in love people use things and so but you
can download those for free and one of
those rules is the no junk rule and
basically everything you own can fit in
one of three piles it's either essential
it's non-essential or it's junk now when
you see those black friday sales quite
often we're trampling each other for
junk yeah at best we're trampling other
people for non-essentials things that
might add value to our lives but they
aren't truly essential and we can get by
without them right yeah now we panic
quite often because of what we think
that we don't have enough of the
essentials but that's because quite
often we're treating these
non-essentials or even these junk items
as though they are essential
and so we never stop to ask that
question what is enough how much is
enough food
what's going to happen if i run out of
paper towels what's going to happen if i
run out of pasta what's going to happen
if i run out of rice or i run out of
meat or whatever it is what is going to
happen in these scenarios am i going to
starve to death if the answer that is
yes then it's probably an essential for
you right
but if you run out of detergent one week
you're still going to be fine yeah and
and recognizing that you're going to be
fine
is the way to
deal with that fear that anxiety that
fear of missing out because realizing
like hey i'm probably not missing out at
all right but b even if i am missing out
i'm missing out
on non-essentials or maybe
i'm missing out on junk that i don't
need in the first place yeah
the the toilet paper shortage that that
really cracked me out man because
you literally have a bath
in the room
where your toilet is like toilet paper
don't get me wrong like i still view it
as an essential but there are very very
easy substitutes for that yes and the
fact that people were panic buying it
just kind of just kind of blew my mind
man and so i think panic buying is one
instance of
why some of these supply chain shortages
are there there are several other
reasons right now that we see these
empty shelves
and we're going to talk more about that
on the maximal episode this week but i
think part of it has to do with also the
the people who work at a lot of these
stores if a bunch of people get sick at
once
the coffee shop across the street i was
just talking to them about this there's
a blue bottle of coffee across the
street and i was there yesterday and i
was like hey thank you guys for being
here you know happy new year etc etc and
just grateful that that you're here and
they they said that they had to close 11
of their stores
because of
illness outbreaks whether it was covet
or something else so enough people were
sick they just could not staff the
stores well if you have the people who
stock the shelves or anywhere else in
the supply chain yeah the the truck
drivers the delivery people if it breaks
down anywhere in that sequence all the
way to the cashier or the person who's
bagging your
groceries if one or two of those links
is missing all of a sudden the whole
supply chain
is interrupted yeah that's something i
really uh noticed during this pandemic
is how
easy easily the supply chain chain
breaks down
and we take a lot of things for granted
even truck drivers like you know i i
think about being on the highway and you
know the truckers uh they're always
going slow in the slow lane or like
they're next to each other like you know
i i would find myself getting irritated
at truckers yes and
that has changed but that now i look at
them like oh like
yes i'll give you some of the road i'll
do whatever i can like without the truck
drivers we don't have the supply chain
yes you know you know where this panic
buying comes from too man the majority
of it what's that
the news um
because i can't tell you how many times
i've seen over the last two years the
news will say something like oh there's
going to be a gas shortage
and then all of a sudden there's a gas
shortage because people are buying it
because the news said there was going to
be a shortage
um same thing with like uh
it's self-fulfilling prophecy in a way
exactly yeah so yeah it's um
yeah it's kind of irritating though like
it's almost irresponsible of the media
to cause this panic buying yeah it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy so
um that's why i watch the news anymore
yeah well and i think you're bringing up
a great point in fact even if there are
supply chain issues and there's panic
buying without the media panic
you're adding fuel to an existing fire
right and so there are actual supply
chain issues and when someone shows up
at the store i noticed this this past
last summer we were in tennessee
and there had been several supply chain
issues there you and i were down there
with dave ramsey and we we were doing
some stuff and i went to just a whole
foods to stock up on some food while i
was in town and i noticed entire aisles
where ryan they
they printed out
groceries and put it in the aisle to
make it look like there were groceries
there i felt like i was in some
communist country or something sounds
like north korea i've seen that in north
korea where they do that and so they
were doing this in
nashville or franklin tennessee right
yeah and it freaked me out but i also
understood it looked better than the
sort of empty shelves you wanted to be
still aesthetically pleasing but they
just had some sort of supply chain issue
and and what that causes and people see
that they say uh oh there's only uh
seven rolls of toilet paper left or
seven i might as well go and get all of
them now because this is all that's left
yeah and so it starts the panic buying
which now there's this small
conflagration and the media comes on and
says oh my god hey everyone don't panic
but you should panic
don't panic but hey everyone else is
panicking yes
calm down while everyone else panics and
in fact that would be my message to
myself here is anytime i see this panic
buying
i also feel that inclination maybe i
should also stock up yeah and so
i just step back for a moment and and
ask myself
what do i need and what is enough
and if i can answer that with respect to
any individual item but then also answer
it more broadly do i actually have
enough and if the answer is no then what
do i need to get there usually to get to
enough we already have too much and it's
about subtraction in these times where
there are shortages you may not have
enough of something and the question
then is is there a substitute or
can i go without for a period of time
yep yeah
so did you see anything during the
pandemic thus far
uh in a grocery store anywhere where you
were checking out and you saw like
someone panic buying a certain
certain something yes and it's
staggering yeah the things yeah so yeah
so what was it for you uh the two well
obviously we know about the paper towels
toilet paper all that stuff right i saw
someone with an entire cart full of
liquor
like a whole shopping cart
brimming i i don't even know like it
seemed like it'd be so heavy i don't
even know how you would i can't believe
you can't call me out like that on this
podcast
[Laughter]
guys i swear it was for my company right
oh man that reminds me of uh uh well
yeah it reminds me of a video of one of
um
the the higher-ups like one of the
highest ups
in the jehovah's witness organization
he was filmed buying a grocery cart full
of like mcallen liquor anyway yeah maybe
that's who i saw well it's funny because
i saw like i was just reading yeah maybe
i was reading on youtube some of the
comments under the video and like
jehovah's witnesses were like coming to
his defense like
oh well maybe it was for other people i
mean it was just it was just hilarious
man but but yeah liquor i saw wine i saw
cookies
i saw this guy with like panic buying
cookies panic buying cookies and i'm
just thinking to myself
man if you're stuck
and
the the only food you have are cookies
like you're you're okay with that
like
i don't know man i mean maybe for today
yeah right exactly yeah and so there are
certain things where it doesn't make any
sense to buy a lot of them period
and it almost never makes sense to panic
by anything yeah
because there are actual times to panic
if you are in a jungle with a lion
that's attacking you or you're walking
down the street and someone
holds you up at gunpoint
you're going to feel a panic response
naturally
the problem is we're now having that
same response to cookie shortages yeah
to alcohol shortages
and maybe we can just step step back for
a moment for a day for a week for a
month and say hey
can i do
without this
let's move on to our callers ryan if you
have a question or comment for our
podcast give us a call 406. 219 7839 or
email a voice memo to our good friend
podcast shawn his email address is
podcast at
theminimalists.com looks like we have a
question here from prince edward island
in canada kay has a question for us do
you guys
pay for ex extra health care insurance
or
is this just something that you guys
save up
um and then when a cost arises you just
pay out of your money
um
basically i'm wondering this because i
find that my
health care insurance is usually more
than what
i would just pay
if i didn't pay my insurance company so
i think i would save money if i
cancelled my health care insurance ryan
pei is the only province we have not
been to another
beautiful over there yeah so we have to
do a tour stop up there one day we're
gonna do the uh everywhere we've never
been tour that's uh so our friend austin
hartley leonard has a uh
one of the best eps of all time
in fact it's probably my favorite ep
it's like five perfect songs it's called
everywhere i've never been
and ryan and i there are nine states we
haven't done tour stops in we've been to
49 states we haven't been to alaska the
united states we haven't done tourists
upstate and there's one province we
haven't done tour stops in and so yeah
we could do it everywhere we've never
been
toward that would be i mean it'd be like
new jersey and delaware it's so rich
it'd be awesome yeah it would be awesome
we'll have to finish in hawaii
or alaska i suppose
but um so they're going from canada
which canada's insurance is set up a
little bit differently yeah so so um
places like canada or the uk have a
universal health care system or some
iteration of universal health care it's
a little bit different from what one
could call universal health care in the
united states like the affordable care
act and i won't get into all of the the
nitty-gritty here because i'm not a
expert on this but i can tell you what
ryan and i do and how we look at this
regardless of where we are so kay i
assume what you're talking about is you
have
government coverage and then there's
also supplemental coverage on top of
that so your government coverage will
cover
catastrophic
uh danger uh
injury
sickness illness disease
treatment etc right
and that's what ryan and i have we have
a insurance plan that is high deductible
yes meaning we pay a lot out of pocket
until we reach a catastrophic deductible
which strange last year i actually met
because of all the health problems i was
going through so i had to pay a lot out
of pocket in addition to my monthly
premium and ryan's monthly premium that
that he pays and so
i think this is a simple calculation
here the way i look at insurance
is it's an emergency item that i hope i
never have to use
i look at my health insurance now we
tend to tie emotion a lot to health
insurance in a way we don't with like
life insurance we were just renewing our
life insurance policy ryan and making
some changes to that there's not a whole
lot of emotion to us like hey if i die
ryan gets some money if ryan dies i get
some money
and uh same with our wives we have
separate policies for our wives right if
if you die mariah will
be taken care of and if i die backs will
be taken care of and then with my car
insurance
uh same thing i hope we were just
renting cars recently we were out on
tour
and they're like oh do you want to use
our coverage like no i already have
coverage right that i hope i don't have
to use on this trip or ever but it is
there and pl in place of or in case of
emergency so emergency items you can go
back and listen to our whole we did a
whole podcast episode about emergency
items podcast john can put a link to
that in the show notes but emergency
items are simply just in case items that
you have
in case of emergencies that ideally an
ideal world they're there for safety you
don't have to use it in a perfectly
healthy world you have health insurance
that you pay for just like you have car
insurance and every month you don't have
to use it yeah it's like a fire
extinguisher yes you know
it's something that uh
you have to constantly buy a new one you
have to get them refilled
but yeah hopefully you never have to
take that bad boy out and use it so in
canada
she so it sounds like if she canceled
her supplemental she would have
the
uh
the national care whatever candidate i
would assume so yes yeah
um i mean she's asking for advice that
for her
it sounds like
yeah maybe you know maybe you could save
so many i'm not recommending that but
i'm just saying for her it sounds like
yeah maybe she could save some money um
but for someone else they might need
that supplemental it all depends on
their circumstances right yeah and
that's why you and i have an emergency
fund so you and i could spend a lot more
per month i know our insurance is like
300 a month
and
and yet we could spend a thousand
dollars a month i'm sure someone will
take our money they have the cadillac
coverage yeah yeah and so if i've spent
a thousand dollars a month now i'd
rather
take that 700 in quote savings
and put that toward an emergency fund so
i have it to cover any sort of
catastrophe right
and so you remember last year ryan you
had to take me to the hospital because i
had to get an mri i had to get a ct scan
and these things are really expensive
they're way more expensive without
health insurance by the way i got the
bill and it was
26 000
for the scan that i got
uh and insurance negotiated it down to
like i forget what it was
2200 2300 essentially 90
off man and and so one of the biggest
problems with our health care system
right now is we don't have transparent
pricing it drives me crazy like ryan if
you get into an accident you need to use
your car insurance
and you take it to the repair shop and
you say well how much is the bumper like
well we'll fix it for you first yeah and
then we'll send your insurance company
no no no you're gonna tell me how much
it costs to replace the bumper otherwise
it's a scam yeah something's wrong with
the way that's set up which might be a
whole other podcast
to talk about insurance but but yeah um
like i'll tell you when i broke my back
i went to the hospital emergency room
emergency room in uh hamilton montana
and everyone was really nice like they
took really good care of me but then he
was like oh we need to do an mri
and i'm like those are pretty expensive
man like can we just do an x-ray he was
like well you know but just trying to
talk me to them around i'm like well how
much does he get me he's like i don't
know
i'm like all right well if that's really
what you're gonna make me do and then
i'm going back and i'm the technician i
was asking her how much is the mri she's
like i have no idea
and then eventually i get a bill and it
was yeah i was like 5 500
so i was in montana my coverage is in
california
so i mean
they wanted me to pay a hundred percent
right and thank god the ceo of that
hospital i forget the name of hospital
um i just wrote him a very nice letter
and just kind of pleading and begging
for him to
um to give me a discount and he gave me
a significant significant discount on
everything that's one thing that
is worth noting ryan
all of these things that we often think
aren't negotiable
are negotiable yeah our friend julian
smith he talks about this if you want to
really deal with your own discomfort
spend an entire week or a month
danny i think you'd thrive doing this
but
anywhere you go ask for just ask for ten
percent off you go you go to the coffee
shop across the street hey would you be
willing to give me 10 off that mm-hmm
well i can't or why oh yeah that'd be
it'd be great if you could i'd really
appreciate it yeah and what it does is
it makes you realize that all of these
so-called fixed prices aren't
necessarily fixed this happened to me
recently and i was uh furious with the
toyota dealership i took my well i took
my car in to get you know regular
maintenance right oil change tire
rotation et cetera et cetera and as soon
as i left the right headlight stopped
working and so i assumed like oh maybe
they accidentally disconnected i
couldn't find this connection so i was
at work i said hey bex can you just take
it in have him look at it
and they
they looked at it they're like oh yeah
just the bulb is burnt out and she's
like okay can you replace it and they're
like well yeah and they did they charged
236 dollars to replace a light bulb good
god
and so i called them up i said hey you
realize you're just taking advantage of
someone right and uh but what backs
didn't also understand is that like they
build her after the fact and
you can say no to some of these things
right
and
it was a great lesson for bex
but under i said hey i've never paid
at a dealership for even for maintenance
whatever the sticker price is not a
single time and she's like really i i
always have and we just assume
that we have to but because you and i
the corporate world that we worked in we
n we know everything is
functionally everything's negotiable
right yeah and by the way it's all
negotiable because you have the ability
to walk away and that's how you tie this
into panic buying
when you're panicking when you feel the
need to panic
it's okay to walk away amen you can
tweet that podcast sean hey k want to
send you a copy of our book love people
use things because the opposite never
works it's a relationship book it's
about the seven essential relationships
in our life it's our relationship with
our stuff our money
which is perfect for this question here
and also our relationship with our
values our self the truth and with other
people with technology with distractions
and so much more
if you enjoy our podcast you'll really
enjoy the audiobook version of that or
if you want the book book or the ebook
version we'll send those to you as well
okay hey alabama do we have any
questions from our patreon live stream
shout out to all our patreon patreon
subscribers watching this live we do we
have a question from nicole she asks is
what you're describing uniquely american
as an idea of panic buying how do other
countries respond to the lack of fear
and the unknown yeah i i wish i could
say it was just an american thing right
but
i know when kazkov had hit in the east a
lot sooner
there was panic buying going on before
in fact
um
i had that trip planned to go to china
in japan
like right right when covet hit right
you were supposed to be there like in
march of 2020 right
yeah
so
as um as the pandem as it started
i get a i get a um message from my
friend who mariah and i are gonna go on
the strip with and he's like
hey man i'm really worried about toilet
paper in japan i'm like what are you
talking about dude
he was like they're panicked buying
toilet paper and he's like we might have
to bring you know some extra rolls with
us or something and at the time i'm like
that's so ridiculous and then it hit in
america and then
realized it wasn't so ridiculous um i
mean it is ridiculous to panic by but i
was like oh there's those japanese folks
they're crazy panda buying toilet paper
but no it turns out everyone starts
panic buying when when things hit the
fan yeah this is a uniquely human
problem
and
it may be
amplified or exacerbated by particular
cultures who are more prone to hoarding
like american culture
we have more things than the rest of the
world what's the sad about children they
make up what three percent of the
world's population yeah three percent of
the world's children yeah american
children make up three percent of the
the world's children but they have like
a ridiculous amount of toys yeah 40 of
the world's toys right and so they they
get that from their parents the kids
aren't going out and hoarding toys their
parents are hoarding toys for them and
teaching them to hoard at a young age
right and you're right though it's not
just america in fact on the maximal
episode this week ryan the more about
less article i have is titled
supermarket shortages are different this
time how to respond and avoid panic and
here's the very first line of the
article
australia has experienced plenty of
supermarket shortages since the covid
pandemic began the emerging crisis is
now a bit different and so
australia is seeing actually even more
shortages than us
and more panic buying
than us right now and it could be
because there's a heightened fear more
fear leads to more panic more panic
leads to more panic buying yeah
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text message
messages so maybe you don't want to call
in and leave a voicemail that's okay you
can text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
do our best to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our minimal maxims in
one place thanks to our good friend
jessica lynn williams that's
minimalmaxims.com
hey alabama it looks like we got a
question here from rebecca
i'm a big believer in keeping a
well-stocked freezer and pantry but i
don't want to go overboard with stocking
up even on things i use where do you
draw the line between preparation and
hoarding
preparation and hoarding you know
there's there's something pithy here
about uh hoarding is in the eye of the
beholder yeah because
the and that's not my pithy answer by
the way but i i think about you know
when i see someone who has a oh we were
we were just with jay nash recently yeah
and he was talking about this in fact he
he was on the podcast a couple years ago
back when we were in the old studio and
he's a very talented musician but he's
also he moved to vermont i don't know a
decade ago
from l.a he's like in la i own next to
nothing in vermont i have more snowshoes
than i had total possessions yeah and he
is also a ski instructor so every one of
his kids he has three kids each one of
his kids has like four pairs of skis and
i'm like do they need it he's like yeah
here's why they need it
and so i see that if i were to walk in
and see all the skis and the snowshoes
or whatever or if i in fact if i had his
stuff in my house i would be hoarding it
yes for him
it's
value-adding non-essentials but they add
immense value to his life and he we'd
actually be depriving him if we said
well you're actually hoarding that you
you really should get rid of it right so
here's my pithy answer for you ryan
perception
is the greatest form
of preparation
and so here's what i mean by that if
your ability to understand what you if
you have an ability to understand what
you need
it's going to help you
be less anxious less fearful less
worried
it's going to make you feel like you're
missing out a whole lot less in fact
you may even find the joy in missing out
if you step back and have that
perception here's uh yeah here's one
more pithy answer for you you won't have
enough until you know what enough is
yeah i know we talked about that with
mira earlier in this episode but you
won't have enough until you know what
enough is quite often we keep trying to
get more because we assume what we have
isn't enough yeah but if you assume what
you have is enough and you start with
that starting point
and if you realize oh maybe i do need a
little bit more then that's okay
but if you already assume you have
enough
you're probably not going to hoard any
excess mm-hmm yeah um
yeah my pithy answer is the simple
things aren't
the easy things i think my original uh
maxim i sent you was uh uh simple ain't
easy yes
yeah and uh
you can look at it either way you know
here's the thing
this is
it takes it takes some discipline it
takes some some forethought
it takes uh being in the present moment
taking an inventory of your life it's a
lot of work to set up these boundaries
yeah it's not easy
and you know what uh they're asking here
is well
tell me
tell me how much do i need to say am i
saving too much of my saving too little
right i don't know
i mean i can say what i do i had um
i had was one of the minimalists that
were community leaders they sent me an
email they're like ryan i'm really
having a problem with the panic buying
um i'm starting to affect me and i don't
know how much food to buy like what do
you and mariah do
and i'm like well
regardless of panic buying or not we
typically keep one week to two weeks
worth of food yes and that's what i've
stuck to
um
and she was like oh that's a great
number and that worked for her and her
family but that may not work that may
not work here for rebecca right rebecca
might need a month's worth you know
mariah's or three days or three days
whatever it is so yeah i mean simply
ain't easy you re you really have to
do the work and but once you set up
those boundaries
then that is where
yes you can experience the joy of
missing out because
you have the appropriate amount of
things you're not worried about food
spoiling you're not worried about where
everything's going to go your house
isn't cluttered full of things and
there's a joy within that yes but to get
there it takes it takes some work in a
way those boundaries give you permission
to let go
i like that we're saying the same thing
what you're saying is
once you've identified what enough is
whether that's two weeks or two days
that's now your boundary and now
boundaries like boundaries in the real
physical world they're adjustable as
well
if you adjust them intentionally you'll
continue to thrive if you just adjust
them willy-nilly because oh my god
something's on sale i might as well buy
it right now i better hurry up and get
it before it runs out of stock that's
not intentional that's not living
deliberately that's reacting to someone
else who's trying to create
panic within you yeah but if you have oh
yeah you know what one week is my number
in fact mine is is about three days we
go to the grocery store twice a week
and and so about three days is my
boundary if i buy beyond that what
happens the food that i tend to buy
spoils yeah and so if it goes bad then
i'm simply creating more waste yeah so
if i go beyond my boundary
i'm creating more waste that is what
rebecca's asking here that's when we're
hoarding
right we got a bunch more to talk about
but first real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalists we um
we just finished up the love people use
things tour well sort of the american
portion of the tour but we had to
postpone our two canadian dates there
were some travel restrictions and some
venue and municipal municipalities who
restricted the amount of people who
could gather in a space at once in
canada and so we have a tour stop in
toronto and one in vancouver both of
those we've had to postpone i believe
until october you can find all the
details over at theminimalists.com
tour
and who knows now that we've postponed
those maybe we'll add a few other cities
in canada i don't know if it'll be pei
but who knows
there's always a chance we'd love to and
maybe they can be in the summer
instead of the winter in canada oh my
goodness man yes we we just came back
from uh as of as of this recording we
came back from new york boston
and washington dc and i think the
warmest i got was like 18 degrees over
there but it was typically like in the
low teens or maybe you know eight or
nine degrees and man i have never first
off southern california has ruined me
when it comes to weather it's weird
though in montana like i was just there
for christmas
and it didn't it didn't bother me like
it did on the east coast i don't know
maybe because it's windier on the east
coast i don't know yeah but man when we
when we landed in lax and it was like
you know 68 degrees yeah i had i have
never felt so grateful for living in los
angeles man um so yeah let's let's do
the canadian stops in the summertime
well we do have two in october so that's
like late summer yeah that's uh late
summer yeah it's uh fall but um yeah and
who knows maybe we'll sandwich a few
others in there if you sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com
you'll be the first to know of any
upcoming tour stops and by the way all
20 of our love people use things tour
events are being published over on
patreon patreon.com the minimalist for
our true fans over there i got to tell
you ryan that new york event we just did
yeah with with seth godin and t.k
coleman t.k coleman yeah i mean yeah um
it's so funny because now i just assume
tk is always there because he's he's the
third minimalist at this point but no uh
that was it might have been
one of the most heartfelt events
we have ever had i think part of it was
i was talking to alabama about this
before we started recording and i think
one of the things that happened is there
were a lot of people who were getting
sick because of you know just winter flu
and then covet and all these other
things that it created this extra
tension that was in the air
and with that tension came some really
heartfelt
questions
that may have not surfaced without some
of that tension that people felt and dc
was very similar to that we had the
brothers coleman there we had ken
coleman and tk coleman there another
great show you definitely want to check
out thousand man yeah we had lisa
lampanelli in boston yeah and jay nash
played music there but you can check all
those out patreon.com
the minimalist alabama what else you got
for us here are some voicemail comments
and insights from our listeners
hey there alexis from new york city so
something that has made me think twice
about what i bring into my home is
donating with purpose so as i've been
downsizing i've been leaving all of my
stuff in a bucket on the floor and i've
really been doing my research to try and
find places that'll actually use my
stuff and you'd be surprised at how hard
it is to find places who will take your
stuff even if it's good stuff
so
in doing all of this work i am finding
meaning and purpose in the things i'm
donating and i'm thinking twice about
what i bring into my home hey guys this
is natalie from colorado and this is the
comment for the minimalist fashion
podcast when someone asked how to keep
clothes in good condition when doing the
333 project
so i usually wear each item of clothing
twice unless they're actually dirty
and then i also wash clothes on delicate
and hang dry everything except for jeans
and gym clothes most items are washed in
garment bags to prevent snags or tears
lastly since i wear a lot of black as
well once my clothes start fading i dye
them to revive the color oh and one last
thing i usually use natural detergents
from a zero-waste store because less
chemicals equals less damage all right
y'all you may have noticed we're doing
some experimentation lately in fact we
were just talking about this on the
patreon live stream we've been getting
the new lights in the studio beulah's
beautiful paintings and tim
uh wove arts built these walls that are
holding up some of the paintings behind
us these sort of roving walls we also
have peter duff who's been helping us
with some of the audio engineering as
well
him and sean are kind of like uh
stockton and malone
sean just passes it to him perfectly
yeah and then uh and then peter he he
dunks it for us but um as we're
experimenting we've been trying some
things out so if you're listening to the
audio version of this you'll notice
something over the last few weeks we
brought back the
peter doran theme song to the opening of
the
i just felt it was missing i heard from
a few people as well when i would listen
to the podcast but then i it was
confirmed by some other folks now the
youtube videos it gets straight to it
we've got the new beautiful opening
bumper if you haven't seen that on our
youtube videos yet by the way we had
some folks over at ramsey solutions
we hired them independently to design
this amazing opening bumper and uh so
we're now
on the audio version we've we've
reverted back to peter doran opening up
the episodes given us that original
sonic branding that we've always had
then every thursday you'll still hear
the the um new attenuated bumper at the
beginning of our quickie patreon samples
that we publish every thursday but then
we're also ending the episodes once
again with the actual audio if it's the
audio version so if you're watching the
youtube version you click up here
somewhere jordan and i'm sure there'll
be some video that we recommend actually
i've got a um i've got an added value
here today that we're going to play a
song out at the end of this but if
you're listening to the audio version
you'll get to hear the song if not you
can because of copyright or whatever on
youtube we don't want to get any
copyright strikes but for added value
this week ryan i um
i watch this documentary
it's called a man named scott i'm sure
you've seen some of the billboards
around
it's uh it's about kid cudi who i don't
know a whole lot about he was sort of
he became really famous at 2009-ish
and i was late to his music in fact i
didn't really start listening to a lot
of his music until a couple years ago he
did an album with kanye west called kids
see ghosts that was the name of the
album wasn't danny yeah and um
and i really dug that seven song album
and he had an album come out the end of
2021 called man on the moon three and
that made me go back and listen to the
first two man on the moon albums and
i remember some of the songs from you
know day and night yeah in fact that'll
be our added value that's what we'll
play them out with today but the actual
added value is this documentary about
him
it is shot so beautifully
and it's exactly remember we've been
working with booklight on another
potential project
and i described months ago here's how
i'd like the next film tool and it's
like they did that in this kid cuddy
documentary oh wow with with these sort
of
inter-weaving
old b-roll footage with really beautiful
talking head interviews and then
these sort of avant-garde shots and and
in fact they even filmed part of this
documentary in a lot of the scouting
locations we went to for lessons now in
fact the place where we filmed lessons
now yeah is even in
this documentary oh that's cool and it's
a beautiful documentary and it goes into
sort of how he accidentally stumbled
into fame and success or whatever but it
was really through being
emotionally authentic and upfront in a
way that hip-hop music at the time
was not willing to to talk about some of
these things about being a loner and
being lonely and being emotionally
sensitive
and his songs really brought that to the
forefront that's funny because i feel
like
the new hip-hop or the new or whatever
like it's all
emotional being a loner
yeah and i think you could argue there
were maybe some progenitors to that
before kid cudi but he was the one who
really brought it to the forefront
and uh so let's let's play out with uh
dan knight which is his most famous song
but i think that'll give you a sample
for folks who aren't familiar with his
work here's uh kid cudi day and night or
you can watch the video if you're
watching this on youtube just click up
here somewhere by the way we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
how do we deal with the fear of missing
out the results from uncertain times
what are the minimalist thoughts on bulk
food stores like costco or sam's club
how much and what kind of food should we
keep on hand to be prepared without
being wasteful or greedy plus a million
more questions for me and ryan if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com the minimalist to
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our weekly private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app you also gain
immediate access to hundreds of hours of
private archives recordings of live
events exclusive home tours and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers like you you can
follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social jess danny unknown emma the
immigrant
and the rest of our team i'm joshua
fields milburn reminding you to love
people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it